600人ほんとにおめでとうこれからもがんばってくださいありがとうございますもう
600入ってるよありがとうございます600万におめでとう
臼歯におめでとう600万人おめでとうロペ rar
ざっ采配今日肇社長でパズメッツォチャンネルチャンネル登録車
ロンメイクマンに超えましたーーー
ん
レって日本の人口だと約20人に1人ぐらいは僕マンチャンネルを登録する計算になる
んで
[音楽]
怖いです素直に怖いです山岡全然村 aa 地学が全く足りないんですけどもまぁ今後
も変わらず糞っましょう v ない皆さんの暇潰しになれるような動画を出すという
ことをいますのでこれからもよろしくお願い致します
という気で質問コーナー
やっていきますそして言っている通り動画が最後にちょっと重大なお知らせがあるので
ぜひお楽しみに
飛ばさないでね飛ばさないで質問コーナーでは以降ゴミ箱に入って
だけで肇社長さんはい
持った
形でじゃあねあをしゃべるにスタンプ連打してみていや全然やりますけどねこりゃ
もうものも知らねぇぞもうれ身内からねこれ
合わせた権限じゃっ
[音楽]
なぜからあの人普通に起こりそうなんですけど
the 件なメロンパンでミルクて注ぎ込んで見たな
なにこれなにこれなにこれはすぎ無下に染み込むんでこれうまいのかねいただけます
そうでもね早くに電話してできます
朝に忙しいかなと忙しいんですよや君たちべっ
すっ
[音楽]
stay
よっているしねえどちゃ好き合ってパパイパパ
バー
うんてぺぺーシェ
何見てるんですパパパパ
ni
大きな声で発狂性能バー
うん
おっもしもしアンもし走っ
あれあれもしもしあれ今日の世
あればつながってねっ
なんだこれはブーンだとそうなるか見てあなたを取ってる普通
面接官の美女の時の反応あとてるじゃん
よろしくお願い今日はよろしくお願い致します
これ
どうしました
以上ですか今オススメなに目は今おすすめのアニメ
うーんそうですね
から会場図の高木さん人生で初めてもらった感じで笑ってみて
[音楽]
ポン期にあたることがしゃべってうわぁわぁわあ
あ
ああああああああ
まあまあバーバー
パワー
あっ弟がもうちょいで誕生日だからヒビキくん誕生日おめでとうって言ってほしい
シビックん
[音楽]
誕生日
おめでて言わねえよ
おめでとうクリーナー好きですかず質問
[音楽]
いいえ
エアーブリッジたまま片手でコーラ飲んでください
うーん
ああああああ
me
わさびを購入すれば食ってください
スパッ日
パパ
バンッ
ほっちゃんに電話で切れて
んわーこの hey my さあ
ほんとさぁ人気んだよ魔イサーン
どんなべっ嫁
違うなお自由んだよだったからってお前さほんとさぁ
[音楽]
早く体調直せよああ
わかったかライアンが分かった熱何度今
メロ今日はあれだ指か動物けどやだ
やっぱ誕生日頭ぶつけてやだ愛してでも小指ぶつけていいやロックマン2を見ると小指
ぶつけてやなぁ vivi つけろやだビルつけてやっぱりぶつけてくださるビューと
角に小指をどうするって言われてるほどこれやって
白い恋人いって小指ドアをドンドンドンドンた壁というかどうすればこれ
goon 歌舞伎であった nao
[音楽]
そうしてだよあぁうぅうう
ええええええ
はいというわけで質問してくださった皆様本当にありがとうございました
過去最高レベルでちょっと激しかった気がします25だよもう25なんですけどまぁ
からなかって乱暴だところがあるんで
楽しかったです歳で英重大発表でございますちょっとここからまぁちょっと真面目な話
になってしまうかもしれません
前髪なまあな匂いようこそちゃんとまとまってないんですけどまぁ1年前から2年前
くらいからとてもありがたいことにものすごく
あの
youtube とかゆうつべ以外でいろんな場所で活躍させて頂いておりますことに
ありがたいことで非常に楽しいんですけどあのそれに伴ってこれもたぶん去年から言っ
てたのかな
去年から言ってたと思うんですけども時間的にも体力的にも
ひとりだとちょっと
苦しいなっていういろんな面でいろんな人にまあ支えてもらっております動画には釣れ
ないんですけども動画の裏でサブチャンネルほぼ全部編集してもらっている友達とかも
行ったりなんかちょっとしたものの準備とかカメラとかなんか来ないことを手伝って
もらってる仲間がすごいいって本当に僕
ぼっちだったんですよ結構マジでね何か良い友達は入れているんですけどめちゃくちゃ
毎回遊ぶわけでもないし基本的に一人で行動していることがずっと多くてそれで寝たら
youtube にこう
専念してこれたっていうことはあったかも知れませんただその分やっぱり全部一人で
やらなきゃいけなくて忙しくなってきた中で
でもう色々といろいろと
時間的な苦しさ人数的な苦しさをすごいうわーもうこれ基地なーっておも部分が多くて
ですねそこであの一人じゃなくて手伝ってもらう人も付けようと思っていろんな人に
手伝ってもらったり
今支えてくれる人が
たくさんいます結果的に言うと bot じゃなくなりました
動画だと一人ですけどあのすごい実はいろんな人に支えられて今弾み撮影のチャンネル
をやって言っておりますまあ一人じゃなくなったからそいつらと遊んだりすることも
あってまあそれでもほぼいう業とかなんかカードゲームとかそうもない遊びなんです
けどあの僕の中では
それが物凄い楽しかったプレスいい時もなんか仲間がいたからなんとか乗り越えられ
たってとこもあったし
youtube はじめの頃はもう一人でひたすら突っ走ろうと思ってたんですけど
やっぱり仲間が入ってくれてすごく
僕は救われています今なんだけどもやっぱり youtube だところはず3冊の
チャンネルっていう
和美社長でやるチャンネルみたいなミューズがあって結局動画撮ったり編集したりって
いうのは僕になっちゃうんですけど一人のいろんな限界を感じていくなんかいろんな人
に手伝ってもらったりしていくうちに
あの信頼できる仲間がたくさん増えましたねぇ
ずーっと前から考えてたんですけどもあの
条約
スタートを切る準備が整いましたその最高の仲間と
新しいチャンネル作ればいいんじゃねっていうことで
新しいチャンネルを作りますもちろんはじめしゃちょーう30やめるわけではないです
この残念もちゃんとやりつつもう一つ別個の新しいチャンネルを作ろうと思っており
ます
ようやく行ってしまった実はずっと新チャンネルの準備でいろいろ
しておりましたわからないグループっていいかわかりませんがプライズ俺の回りにいる
最高のメンバーを集めた
チャンネルだと思っております
ちなみにまだ始まりませんあのつずつ作りますああいう
発表だけをちょっと本化したかったなっていう裏でずっとコソコソやってたんで何で別
に何か一人でどうぞ取るのが辛くなったとかそういう理由でも全然なくて体にあの動画
では売ってない僕の周りの奴らかは面白いんでそいつらでもう一個新しいだけど作って
恐れる
を使っていければいいなと思っておりますというわけではじめシャツを新チャンネルを
作るというお知らせでございました
総裁がまた市バスを持つくださいそこでここで誰でお戯れ
メンバー募集します皆周りのメンバー最強ってもやっぱりこうみんなで話し合って結果
もう一にほしいなっていういろいろあるんですよいろいろ話し合った結果ちょっともう
1人増やしてもいいんじゃないかなという話がありまして
メンバーの募集をいたしますというで新メンバーの募集を致しますもう誰でもあったり
と思ったけどねやこれ一応ですね結構決まりがあるんですけどレズ
メイズっていうのは確定で27歳から29歳の方
27歳から29歳までだいたいこんなもんです2678930ぐらいの賭場であの
一緒に new tube を盛り上げてくださる方を募集しております
細かいことはに下の url からを受けるんであのも視力と一緒に
楽しいことをやっていきたいなって思っている方がいらっしゃいましたらご連絡の方を
持つしておる
あのちなみに結構月ですの新チャンネルについてまだ全然言えないことがたくさんある
んですけど大丈夫このチャンネルは全く変わりません
このチャンネル本当に変わらず引き続き行っていくんですけども新しいことをやれて
新しいことをやりたいと思ってあのようやく動き出した
新チャンネル新しいメンバーをひとりだけ募集しておりますあの新チャンネルほんとね
近い打つに動き出せればいいなと思っておりますのでお知らせもちろんあの引き続き
弾み誘うサングそして新チャンネル
me
あまり期待せず待っていて下さいじゃあ
me up
papapa
pa
ああああああ
papapa
pa pa
バッハ